[Music]
morning everybody it is seven o'clock
the fallout from partygate is developing
into something of a charcuterie board
with operation red meat and now an
alleged pork pie plot to oust the pm
from the government today we'll speak to
the armed forces minister james hippie
the conservative peer who used to advise
boris johnson plus the shadow business
secretary jonathan reynolds it is
wednesday the 19th of january
pork pie plot the claims that 20
conservative mps are poised to add their
weight to plans to topple the prime
minister over partygate after this
yesterday from their leader
nobody told me and nobody's nobody said
that
uh this was something that was against
the rules it was a breach of the of the
cobid rules
the rules that he made of course now
will have the latest twists and turns as
the pm prepares for prime minister's
questions with an olive branch to back
benches to announce an easing of plan b
restrictions
cost of living crisis the latest
inflation figures are out this morning
we'll bring them to you live this hour
and what it means for your family bills
island evacuations homes destroyed and
water contaminated in tonga with a race
to get aid there after the underwater
volcano eruption
don't be complicit amnesty
international's warning of a sports
washing propaganda exercise at the
beijing winter olympics next month
also on the programme for you this
morning
why do i want to know about your son
because he killed mine
how far back would you like to go
wherever you need
we'll also speak to the actress martha
plimpton about her role in the new sky
film exploring the aftermath of mass
school shootings in the us
give it a stir and what we're after is
like a bright yellow paste so you see
that this is exactly what we want so
it's quite loose and how to cook lean
green meals that don't bust the bank
we'll chat to chef miguel barclay about
his recipes that only cost a pound per
person
[Music]
morning everybody big day for the prime
minister another big day for the prime
minister sky news understands that
around 20 newly elected conservative mps
are poised to add their weight to a
leadership challenge on the prime
minister the mps who were first elected
when they broke down labour's red wall
in 2019 met in secret yesterday it's
being called a pork pie plot why well
because one of the mps believed to be
involved is the mp for melton mowbry
famed of course for its port pie is very
good they are too if you're watching
this morning now there is strong
speculation tory mps may nearly have the
amount of letters needed to get a no
confidence vote in boris johnson that is
54. so let's analyze what's needed to
trigger that vote of no confidence
a leadership contest can be triggered if
15
of 360 conservative mps send handwritten
letters to the chair of the 1922
committee declaring their intention to
oust the prime minister
a vote of no confidence then commences
where if more than 50 percent or 181 mps
vote against mr johnson he will be
ousted with immediate effect
however if mr johnson happens to win a
no-confidence vote he has the right to
remain unchallenged for the next 12
months our chief political correspondent
john craig reports
the haunted look of a prime minister on
the brink boris johnson faces mps today
knowing his time as pm may be coming to
an
end
it's some of these mps newly elected
many in so-called red wall seats just
over two years ago in 2019 who are
leading a mutiny against mr johnson
it's claimed 20 of them are poised to
submit letters after prime minister's
questions demanding a no-confidence vote
taking the number close to the 54
required to trigger a contest
the coup is being called a pork pie plot
because one of the mps involved
represents rutland and melton home of
the melton mowbry pork pie
the rebels claimed mr johnson's tv
interview yesterday on allegations of
downing street partying was a disaster
nobody told me and nobody's nobody said
that
this was something that was against the
rules it was a breach of the of the
cobia rules we were doing something that
wasn't a a work event because
uh
frankly i don't think
uh i can't imagine why on earth it would
have gone ahead or why it would have
been allowed
hello how are you doing
facing a nervous way to find out his
fate the prime minister will today try
and resuscitate his faltering leadership
by announcing he's ripping up england's
plan b covert restrictions which are
opposed by so many of his mps
the changes are likely to include
ditching covid passports and working
from home guidance although mandatory
mask wearing in some settings could
remain
before the cobit announcement however
another make or break pmq's with more
questions about downing street parties
awaits
the prime minister heads for the house
of commons and prime minister's
questions today knowing that his job is
on the line
after his downbeat tone and his forlorn
appearance in his tv interview yesterday
he'll be aiming to come out fighting
he'll need to
the mood in parliament is feebrial and
the prime minister's position is today
more perilous than it's ever been
john craig sky news
well the minister for the armed forces
james hippie is with us now hello to mr
heapey thanks for joining us on the
program this morning much appreciated
challenging time for all ministers uh
what about this pork pie plot how much
trouble is the prime minister in
well i mean i only know what i've read
in the papers overnight that some
colleagues uh appear to have met to
discuss things um i don't think that's
surprising i suspect there's lots of
colleagues who are
reflecting on what they've heard in
their constituencies and
are feeling under a lot of pressure
right now because the british public are
absolutely furious with what they've
heard
the prime minister has apologized
i can tell colleagues that in the
meetings i see the prime minister which
are some of the meetings in which we
discuss
the most sensitive matters that the
state has to deal with at a time when
the world is
incredibly unstable
the prime minister is taking really big
decisions and he's making the right
calls and this doesn't feel like the
time to be changing our prime minister
if you ask me
any the problem is he's telling alleged
porcupines which is why there's this
pork pie plot
well i'm not sure i think the connection
that uh john made in his report was it
was to do with the uh melton mowbray
constituency rather than that but i see
your point um i just think that the
prime minister has given his account of
things he did so at the dispatch box
which all ministers take very seriously
that when they stand up at the dispatch
box they have a responsibility to be
absolutely accurate in what they say
others have contested that version of
events and said they're willing to do so
on oath
um we all wait to see what sugray has
heard and the conclusions that she makes
yeah he went into the garden he saw
people gathered and he said he didn't
think to ask
why they were there in his garden
yeah i was his i mean i think that this
to most people who don't hang around in
downing street and haven't seen the way
that the prime minister's day is put
together that will sound absurd but the
reality is
that the prime minister's day is put
together in five minute blocks i spent
six months as his parliamentary private
secretary
running around in downing streets and
around westminster behind him and it is
the most extraordinary job you can
bounce from a national security council
meeting straight into a meeting with
fellow ministers on a domestic policy
issue straight into a phone call with a
foreign leader and then someone comes
and grabs you from your office and takes
you down to the garden and in the 30
seconds that that takes to go down the
stairs you get a pre-brief on what is
going on yeah and during the 25 minutes
that you're there minister you see a
trestle table full of peanuts and pinot
grigio and you don't think hmm i make
the rules and i'm sure that's against
those rules
well i think in the prime minister's
statement he acknowledged that when he
was there he realized and he you said in
hindsight he should have stopped it
there and then
so he did break the rules
well he made his statement
it is for sue gray to determine whether
or not you just said minister with all
due respect you just suggested that he
broke the rules because he realized that
it was against the rules um and so he
went back inside and left everybody else
outside quaffing their white wine
what i did is reflected on the statement
that the prime minister made to
parliament the other day and i repeated
his words
nobody told me he said nobody told me i
was breaking the rules he makes the
rules
well as i said i can perfectly imagine
from having worked closely with him and
in number 10
exactly how
this happened he will have been grabbed
from his office at the end of a busy day
of very significant decisions around the
pandemic and everything else that was
going on in the world and would have
been launched into an event which he
himself said at the dispatch box in
hindsight he should have shut down
immediately
yeah but he didn't and as a result he
broke the rules
and he has apologized for what that's
not enough though is there he broke the
law
well he was at a party with 40 people in
the garden
we are all keen to
uh understand exactly what happened and
whether or not it was uh
breaking the law and
we are waiting for the sugray report to
come back
and if it was then what happens
well i think let's see what the report
says and i'm happy to come back on and
offer my reflections there
straightforward question minister if you
don't mind me uh putting it to you uh
again if a prime minister breaks the law
does he have to step down
well i i don't want to get into
hypothesis
well simply because i know how these
things work and what ends up being is in
answering your hypothetical question
with a hypothetical hypothetical if a
prime minister breaks the law it looks
as though this prime minister has broken
the law i've given you some of the facts
if he's broken the law should he step
down because he has misled parliament if
he has broken the law i think it is
perfectly reasonable to wait for sue
gray's reports to come back and then for
each and every member of parliament and
member of the government to reflect on
the conclusions of that report not
everybody's as supportive as you are not
only these pork pies but um rishi sunak
his chancellor who lives next door where
one of the photographs was seen from the
garden uh was taken from he left so
quickly yesterday at the end of an
interview he forgot to take his
microphone off um
it doesn't sound as though he has
complete faith in in the prime minister
does it
i think
everybody in government everybody in
parliament is acutely concerned about
what has happened and
the reaction of the public
our boss is not the prime minister our
boss is those who send us to westminster
to represent us
and they are furious at what they have
heard and so it doesn't surprise me in
the slightest that every single member
of the government every single member of
the party
is balancing those two
uh loyalties their loyalty to a prime
minister who has made some really
fantastic decisions over the last year
in uh making the choices over the
vaccination program in making some brave
choices before christmas around omicron
in making some brave choices but the way
it's been in arrogance aware of all of
that minister uh do you have some
sympathy with the pork pie mps who were
elected in 2019 they went home to their
constituencies last weekend and they
were absolutely battered
on the doorstep by furious constituents
do you have some sympathy with them
we all were i have sympathy with every
colleague because this is not easy
but i just reflect that
our economy is in the best shape
our route out of the pandemic seems more
certain than for many other countries
and the thing that absolutely nobody is
talking about right now and yet is the
top of my inbox
every morning here in the ministry of
defense is that two major industrialized
tier one militaries
are not sure that's the topic
if you're looking at your constitution
i'm
i said the top of my inbox here in the
mod
is ukraine
okay uh talk to me uh about the red meat
that's being tossed around um in the
house of commons at the moment the plan
ridiculed yesterday by mps um when we
were talking about the suggestion that a
boat should be taken into the channel
and sonar and all sorts of things aimed
at them to try to get them to go back
once they came
uh no i think the the ridicule was on
something different uh i was discounting
what you've just described as a method
of intercepting or deterring
yeah and do you think it's a good idea
what using a sonic cannon yeah
no i said so in the comments yesterday
okay so why was it even touted
well i think that there has by your
government well i think people have been
looking at all and every option but the
prime minister has asked the mod and the
royal navy to now take primacy over
operations in the channel
and
in our view that is not a method that we
think will be remotely useful in
tackling uh the challenge that we've
been set
one thing we should applaud is the um
service personnel who did their absolute
best to get as many people out of
afghanistan as quickly as possible as
that regime began to crumble and you're
going to honour them today
we are
and i think that that is right
a thousand people will receive a medal
for their service during operation
pitting
those who remember back to august will
remember
the most extraordinary pictures brought
to us most harrowingly by your own
correspondent
we had men and women who were having to
fly planes onto a runway that they
knew was insecure we had extraordinary
soldiers stood outside the barren hotel
having one hand on a rifle and taking
people's babies with the other hand
i
spent some time in the military i won
the number of medals but i did so for
six month tours
this was 14 days of the most
extraordinary intensity the most
extraordinary danger and required the
most extraordinary compassion and i
think it's entirely right that the air
crews and the soldiers and sailors and
aviators that served in kabul during our
pitting will be recognized by her
majesty the queen
just a thought before i let you go back
to uk politics i'm reading in my morning
newspaper that power firms have um
energy firms have given their bad debt
to debt collectors and they've gone
round to people's homes to say we want
our money uh
25 27 of homes are likely to be in fuel
poverty as a result of the increase in
fuel crisis in fuel prices uh by april
by the spring it cannot be right that
we're sending debt collectors around can
it surely you'll look at that
well it's the it sounds to me as it's
the energy companies not the government
but i share your concern that that is
the case uh at a time when families are
very concerned about the cost of living
there are interventions the government
has made
through uh the price cap which remains
in place and the 500 million household
support fund and i know the business
secretary is looking at what more needs
to be done but i would hope that just as
the government is seeking to turn every
stone in order to help people with the
cost of living challenge so to the
energy companies might show uh
people a bit of slack uh if they're
struggling to pay their bills
okay um it's good to talk to you this
morning we always appreciate you taking
the time to join us thank you hopefully
see you in the studio next time quick
question do you like pork pies
um yeah although i'm not sure it's
necessarily the first thing i'll grab
off the supermarket shelf but if i'm
offered one i'll have a slice more than
as i am there's nothing better than a
melting mowery pork pie trust me you
should try a bit of mustard on the sign
fabulous i look forward to seeing you
soon minister thank you bye-bye
bye
boris johnson will come under more
scrutiny in the house of commons this
afternoon there will be full and live
coverage of prime minister's questions
here on sky news at uh 12 o'clock and uh
i know that lots of you were fascinated
by that yesterday last week will wonder
what the prime minister has to say for
himself this morning find out midday
exactly here on sky news
before all that though how much are your
bills going up let's find out helen
anne's here hi good morning good morning
well look it's yet another month where
we sit here and say that the data is
backing up very much what families are
already feeling that the cost of things
is rising and it's rising very quickly
uh so the cpi we're looking at the
consumer price index it's the standard
cost of a an average basket of goods and
services and it rose by 5.4 percent in
the 12 months to december that k is the
largest inflation rise in 30 years which
is really significant and it's actually
i think the third time in a row that
i've sat here the first months and i've
sat here to you and said it's higher
than what economists predicted as well i
think they expected it to be about 5.2
percent it's radically above the bank of
england's target at 2 so really a sense
that this cost of living crisis we're
seeing that so many families are facing
uh continues unfortunately the other
reason why it's so significant is we
found out just yesterday as well that uh
the pro the sort of the the rate of
inflation has now outstripped uh the
rate of wage rises and of course that
really matters because inflation and
price rises can be managed a bit as long
as wages are rising uh in line with them
we found out yesterday that in november
actually workers had a real terms pay
cut of 1
and given that that was just november
unfortunately that's probably set to
continue uh in the months to come
there's a few drivers to all this uh the
price of energy we know a lot about the
price of fuel the price of food uh all
going up and at the bank of england
again you know they have the tool of
raising interest rates they're one tool
they have to try and keep some of this
heat out of the economy they did raise
them just a little bit in december but
they'll also want to look at keeping
them low because that's how the economy
is supported out of difficult times and
it has been difficult times so a very
difficult balancing act for them
certainly the government i think will be
concerned about these
thanks very much indeed thanks a lot
still to come on the program for you
this morning we'll speak to the shadow
business secretary jonathan reynolds
about the rising cost of living and
continued pressure mounting on the
government over allegations of parties
during lockdown
we'll also be getting reaction to that
from tony blair's former director of
communications and that of course is
alistair campbell
[Music]
and what impact is the rising cost of
living crisis having on britain's food
banks chatting to taz khan founder of
the london community kitchen to find out
well outside of the problems he faces as
a result of those parties in downing
street the prime minister is expected to
update parliament this afternoon on the
government's plans to relax plan b
coveted restrictions in england our
science and technology editor tom clark
has spoken to the director of the
welcome trust and former government
adviser sir jeremy farah about what
restrictions he thinks should still
remain in place
i wouldn't lift everything at the end of
january when the nhs is still under
pressure and we're still in the middle
of course of winter so i would
cautiously lift um much of plan b at the
end of january uh but i would keep masks
in place in public transport indoor
places
looking at the latest covid data for you
should we have a quick look and this is
what france has reported close to half a
million new coronavirus cases that
compares to what you can see on the
screen um 94 000 new cases in the uk 438
new deaths uh the total uk deaths 152
152 513
a legal challenge is to be launched in
the welsh government over its mandatory
kovid pass policy
civil liberties campaign group big
brother watch is seeking a judicial
review of the scheme which they say is
discriminatory
now breakfast time have a quick look at
these images
double 07 of the former health secretary
in the telegraph
mr hancock was pictured going for a dip
in the serpentine in london's hyde park
yesterday while out on his morning run a
member of the lake swimming club said
the mp definitely broke the rules with
the impromptu swim saying swimming in
the lakes is for members only
well the express also has the story with
the twist they make the comparison with
the former bond star daniel craig saying
the former health secretary has a
license to chill
we'll let you make up your own minds on
that and let me know what you think on
twitter at k burley
mr hancock spent plenty of time in
number 10 but is the party over for
those in downing street the guardian
this morning with this telling shot of a
sweep a street cleaner a street sweeper
at the
scene of the alleged
rule breaking parties
first ships carrying emergency aid to
tonga have left new zealand five days
after that devastating underwater
volcanic eruption let's take a closer
look at the impact on the islands making
up of tonga
around a hundred thousand live on
tonga's many islands the underwater
volcano
erupted on saturday in an area which is
uninhabited tronga's capital is said to
have suffered limited to moderate damage
with some flooding
the
high pay group of islands has seen
extensive damage with all but the
largest buildings destroyed or severely
damaged
the greatest fears are for smaller
islands including the islands of mango
with an entire village reportedly
destroyed catastrophic damage was also
reported on the island of atata as our
southeast asia correspondent siobhan
robbins reports
this is what it sounds like when a
volcano erupts
it was kind of like bombs were just
going off around the place so we knew
that something catastrophic had happened
we knew it was a volcano but
um
we we knew it was so far away it was
just surprising that it was actually
shaking the buildings here you know
concrete buildings were shaking with
these explosions
tonga's tsunami and volcano have caused
catastrophic damage
destroying whole villages on some
islands
we're kind of in the dark there's no
effective communication between the
islands
we're just kind of in this state of of a
fearful limbo really
the focus is now on getting aid to those
in need the us the latest country to
pledge support
they may save these to
collect rain water
this warehouse in california is
gathering essentials
water supplies have been contaminated so
that's a priority
but falling ash is causing delays
in the national airport needs to be
clear the landing strip unfortunately is
covered with
volcanic eruption ash so
that's a huge challenge for any plane to
land in tuanga and
we have
hundreds of volunteers that are working
with the front liners and also emergency
work to clean up
australia and new zealand have already
started sending ships
on board food shelter and expert teams
to assess the damage
but covet-free tonga is cautious
supplies may be quarantined
we can support uh by air if possible and
if their covert
arrangements can take account of
providing humanitarian aid that we would
help with water because that is the
immediate demand as well as
communications as further surveillance
flights are readied the first
international aid is due to arrive on
friday
almost a week after disaster struck
well siobhan uh joining us now with the
very latest uh live from bangkok
actually um hello to you
siobhan um we don't know on about the
death toll because it is a long way away
from anywhere really isn't it and the
ships are on their way but it still
could take some time
yes that's right it's actually fairly
positive news so far i just spoke to an
aid worker who said that some of her
team had managed to go to some of those
outer lying areas which are really badly
affected they noticed and took note of
all of the buildings that have been
destroyed but so far it appears on the
surface that thousands of people have
managed to get to safety we know that
the death toll officially is three as
you say that could change but the big
focus now is on getting fresh water to
the people on the island new zealand is
bringing 250 000 liters on one of the
ships it's sending it will then be able
to make another 70 000 liters with
resources that it has on board but
really because many of the people on
tonga collect rainwater which has either
been polluted by ash or by salt water
when the tsunami came came in getting
fresh water to them is really the focus
now
okay thank you thanks a lot jamon thank
you
uh looking at today's other headlines
for you now let's start with the ukraine
should we u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken has arrived in kiev for talks
with ukraine's president russia has sent
around a hundred thousand troops toward
its border with ukraine with u.s
officials saying yesterday they believe
that russia was capable of launching an
attack
anthony blinken is set to meet his
russian counterpart in geneva on friday
every single day
listening to this
shooting
this
war has been going on for years now
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey
has visited a village on the front line
of the ukraine russia conflict with only
11 remaining residents you can catch
more from his latest report on the sky
news website
a man in his 30s has been arrested in
connection with the murder of aisling
murphy ms murphy was found dead after
going for a run on the banks of the
grand canal in tullamore last wednesday
the arrest comes after the 23 year old
teacher was memorialized at her funeral
mass at saint bridge's church in mount
bolas yesterday
former colombian senator ingrid
bettencourt has announced that she will
contest the presidential election in may
20 years after being kidnapped by
left-wing rebels ms bettencourt was
abducted by the marxist farc rebel group
and was held hostage for more than six
years before being released freed i
should say by the army
two u.s mobile networks have agreed to
limit the rollout of their new 5g
service following safety concerns from
airline bosses
boeing and airbus via the mobile
technology may interfere with sensitive
airline instruments rendering aircraft
unusable
over to canada where a woman's been
rescued after she crashed through the
ice on a river in monatic
she was seen speeding across the rideau
river in ontario before her vehicle sank
my goodness she was able to climb to
safety and for some reason took a selfie
before she was rescued by onlookers who
had to get to her by kayak she's been
charged
with dangerous driving and police warn
people in their region to keep their
cars on the road and not on the ice
and this next story gives walking in a
winter wonderland a whole new meaning
here we go a dangerous storm made
landfall in the u.s east coast on monday
bringing in heavy snowfall and
thunderstorms meteorologists say a foot
or more of snow fell in parts of new
york and ohio prompting motorists in
cleveland to grab their shovels and
basically just start digging the weather
caused power outages and hundreds of
flight cancellations
looking at our top stories for you this
morning on the programme prime minister
will face pmqs later today knowing that
his job is on the line as pressure
mounts over downing street parties
separate of that mr johnson is also
expected to address parliament this
afternoon about his plan to relax plan b
coverage restrictions in england
and emergency aid leaves for tonga and
mid-warnings continued ash fall has
contaminated much of the country's water
supply
[Music]
one hour our top story boris johnson
facing increasing pressure from his own
mps over the downing street parties
earlier the armed forces minister told
me that even though he understands why
people at home may feel angry it's not
the right time to be changing pm
i suspect there's lots of colleagues who
are
reflecting on what they've heard in
their constituencies and
are feeling under a lot of pressure
right now because the british public are
absolutely furious with what they've
heard
the prime minister has apologized uh i
can tell colleagues that in the meetings
i see the prime minister which are some
of the meetings in which we discuss
the most sensitive matters that the
state has to deal with at a time when
the world is
incredibly unstable
the prime minister is taking really big
decisions and he's making the right
calls and this doesn't feel like the
time to be changing our prime minister
if you ask me
tomorrow is here the pork pie plot
what's it all about yes james heaphy was
saying it's not time to change the prime
minister quite a lot of the newly
elected 2019 mps don't forget make up
about a third of the conservative party
now in parliament those elected in 2019
met yesterday a ringleader of that is
said to be the mp alicia cairns who
represents the area of rutland and
melton
there she is i'll introduce you to a few
of the so-called plotters she's an
ambitious mp she was very critical of
dominic cummings over the barnard castle
issue uh she is not in the red so-called
red wall the uh you know the northern
seats that the conservatives want rather
first rutland issues rutland and that's
why it's been called the pork pie plot
because melton mowbray home of pork pies
is in her constituency
she is one of them another name that has
been mentioned connection this is deanna
davidson now she was very much the sort
of poster girl of the 2019 victory she
took bishop auckland um in the northeast
with a huge majority boris johnson and
carrie johnson campaigned with her and
she's been very high profile in the
media there she is with mrs johnson um
she is very much on the right of the
party she's said to be one of those who
um who is now gunning for the prime
minister and another hello dog lover i
think it was it would seem so yes and um
she's very young still in her 20s also
very ambitious and another one of those
uh 20 is a christian wakeford now he has
actually confirmed to us that he is he
has put in a letter to um ask the prime
minister to resign and what does that
mean so
in order to trigger a leadership
challenge you need mps to send letters
calling for him to resign and if 15
percent of mps do that which currently
will be 50
mps conservative mps send letters to
graeme brady only he knows how many
there are mps will tell you there are 20
or 30 or 40 but they don't actually know
only gray and brady knows graeme brady
is something he is chairman of the 1920s
that's right 1922 committee is all
conservative
mps back bench back benches mps now when
he has 15 of the parties when he has 54
letters he will say there is a
leadership challenge and what happens at
that stage is that there is a vote of
confidence in the prime minister in
parliament so say we reached 54 today
which complicated does the 2019 mps
think think they are nearly there and
are planning to send in their letters
after prime minister's questions if we
if they reach the threshold there'll be
a vote of confidence in the prime
minister now at that stage is a much
higher bar because half of all
conservative mps would be 181
conservative mps would have to vote
against him in order to eject him from
office so remember with theresa may the
letters went in it was 48 needed at that
stage they had the vote of no confidence
and she won and if you win no one can
challenge you again for another year so
so she stayed until she decided to go
because she couldn't get her brexit deal
through parliament so
it is a bad situation for a prime
minister to have a leadership challenge
like this but even if the 54 letters go
in which would be a sign of the very
wide discontent with boris johnson
across the conservative party it doesn't
mean he's a goner because of course
there is still that vote in parliament
and you can imagine that boris johnson
would be fighting that very hard thanks
for unpacking that for us uh tomorrow
that's really complicated you made it
very simple but basically he's in a lot
of trouble he's in a lot of trouble but
is it going to be terminal it all
depends on the numbers and politics you
have to know how to count and of course
the whips will be desperately counting
how many of them are putting their heads
above the parapet okay thanks very much
let's bring in tony blair's former
director of communications should we
alistair campbell of course we chatted
to you last week how do you think it's
looking compared to last week mr
campbell good morning
uh well i think it's it's looking a lot
worse for
johnson but it's just a week in which
the reputation of our country has just
been
dragged through the mud yet again
and all of these conservative mps you've
just shown there smiling with johnson
and
laughing with johnson and celebrating
his arrival in downey street they knew
what they were getting
this idea that suddenly wow we've just
discovered that boris johnson tells lies
boris johnson was a proven liar before
he got to number 10.
and i honestly think that these mps are
only thinking about their own interests
now they're thinking about whether it
helped me to stay as an mp if he stays
or goes they're not thinking about the
national interest some of them might be
but most of them are not they're making
personal political calculations they're
damaging the country they're damaging
themselves he is a terrible prime
minister he is the worst prime minister
we've ever had and he's got to go and
surely they can see that and surely they
can see that the longer they help him
hang on the more they damage themselves
as well
still beat labor though didn't he
he did he did and you know that is what
they thought they got they thought
they'd got a winner because he'd won the
london mayoralty because he
uh he
he won the brexit referendum and then he
won the general election
but this what we're seeing now is what
happens when you put somebody
in that position when they have the
wrong qualities for leadership and to be
prime minister of a great country like
the united kingdom
they couldn't deliver brexit theresa may
couldn't
well listen let me just say this about
brexit k they keep saying that the two
great things that he's done to the
vaccine roll out and got brexit done
brexit is proving to be an unmitigated
disaster for the country our record on
covert is nothing to be proud of with
the death rates and the economic hit and
all the rest that we've done there's
nothing there
and these tory mps i mean it's tragic
for the country
that as over the last decade and before
that when they were
jockeying to get the right their minds
the right people in positions of power
it's always been about the interest of
the conservative party and it is again
now that is the calculation that is
driving the politics of our country and
i hope that people realize when johnson
goes which he will i hope they realize
this is not just about him this life had
a decade they've had more than a decade
we'll be on to our fourth conservative
prime minister and what has this country
achieved in the last decade that they
can take credit for
the furlough scheme didn't he and you
know he made sure that a lot of people
kept their jobs when uh there was
considerable concern um during the
pandemic he made sure that people were
being paid
well look you know the pandemic was
difficult for every government to manage
but this idea that they came up with
these great ideas and don't forget just
two just two days ago
they've written off 4.3 billion pounds
in fraud now is would that have happened
if that had been benefit fraud i don't
think so okay i know you've got to put
the other side when you you know you've
got something like me on here and i get
that
this is the worst government of our
lifetime we have the worst prime
minister of our lifetime we have
somebody who is provenly dishonest
provenly all about himself provenly
lacking integrity and the sooner he's
gone the better the sooner he's gone for
the for the country that's the that's
the most important thing but i say to
all these tory mps who are having their
sleepless nights and is it the right
thing to do it will help me win my seat
or lose my seat and all that do the
right thing just for once find a spine
do the right thing tell him to go and
he'll be gone
yeah and if he goes then downing street
will once again be full of old itonians
some might say and that as a result they
will lose their red wall seats which is
why a lot of mps are still
doddering about and dithering about what
they should do
well that's for them to do i'm just
saying do the right thing
is this guy as prime minister
and this cabinet are they good for the
country or not
and
all they've got to say is he got brexit
done which is a disaster and he's and
he's done the vaccine rollout which has
been good up to the point of recent
weeks where actually we're now in the
middle of the pack in the world now he's
a terrible prime minister that is the
only thing that matters here and this
idea i i was just reading a column in
one of the german newspapers right
they're saying
they find it incredible that he became
prime minister what they also find
incredible is that it takes a party
to tell us that he's so terrible
he's lied about far bigger things than
this this is a guy who lied to the queen
don't forget about prorogation of
parliament this is the guy who lied to
the country about brexit and long after
he's gone the consequences we're going
to be playing them out in the damage to
our economy the damage to our public
services the damage to our standing in
the world you've got a situation
developing in ukraine at the moment
right we are irrelevant
our prime minister in the situation in
ukraine is irrelevant to the world biden
putin do you think they're even thinking
about what the british prime minister
thinks about it no well he has done that
necessarily a fair fight because of
course putin we know what he'll do if
people are up against him and biden's in
the middle of his um
uh presidency so he doesn't need to
worry about uh staying in power let me
just ask you very quickly before i let
you go there let me just ask you quickly
before i let you go as far as sue gray
is concerned this you know there's trash
talking of sue gray has already started
um which to me seems anything but fair
she's trying to do her job to the best
of her ability is it fair to have put a
senior civil servant in to take part in
this um investigation when she's
basically investigating her boss was it
fair and reasonable to put her in that
position to start with
of course it's not
and it's typical
why did sue gray get put into that
position
because the guy that he put into in the
first place this the cabinet secretary
who's disappeared off the face of the
earth so far as i can tell
he had to recuse himself because he was
at one of these wretched parties and by
the way this thing about a drinking
culture in downing street i never saw
anybody drunk in downing street ever in
the years that i worked there i can't
even remember attending a party other
than an official one
and sue gray is a very committed
diligent public servant to put her in
this position
where he wants her basically to sort of
just say you know say something that
allows him to get away with it
he's using her
it's just adds to the long list of
disreputable
dishonest things that he's done
and i hope for sue gray's sake i like
sue gray i think she's a very very good
woman
i hope for her sake that actually he's
gone before she has to submit this
report
okay and the people who should be
looking at the people who should be
looking into this are not sue grey it's
the police he's committed a crime inside
downing street and it should be the
police that look into this allegedly
allegedly i'm going to throw that in
there before the lawyers do good to talk
to you thanks very much alistair thank
you
you too
rising inflation figures energy bills
and tax rises conspire to squeeze
household income extra pressure is
mounting on britain's food banks as more
families struggle to keep up
joining us to discuss the impact of
living costs on food banks is taz khan
founder of the london community kitchen
hi taz thanks for joining us on the
programme this morning more and more
people are in full
food and fuel
poverty
is that being reflected where you are
good morning kay thanks for having us on
yes indeed it is being reflected we are
seeing an unprecedented increase
in numbers um in all the boroughs that
we operate in and we are finding a new
group of people that are visiting us
people that are actually finding
themselves that are in full-time
employment but just not able to make it
through the month
how are you coping with that
well we have to work a lot harder and
you know furlough has ended people are
going back to work some people a lot of
people are finding themselves in
unemployment
and we are also struggling with
volunteers because life is trying to go
back to normality but
i think this is the new norm we're
finding ourselves in a new territory
here
and what about enough food are you are
you getting enough supplies to make sure
that everybody who needs to put food in
their belly is able to
yeah so some weeks we do over christmas
we got
a large amount of food that we could
redistribute to communities but we are
struggling uh with fresh fruit produce
it's um
it's a it's a bit of a grim story in
london at the moment
and has are you receiving any support
from the government or your local
council which i'm guessing is harrow
yeah so howard council has supported us
so as a couple of the other london
boroughs including brent
but uh we're seeing that support being
more and more thin it was quite strike
during the pandemic but now
there's an expectancy to just kind of
like get on with it but i really feel
that you know it's uh it's a boiling pot
and it needs to be addressed because
the situation is only going to get a lot
worse in the coming months especially
with all these increases in fuels and
energy prices which are affecting every
single average household that we support
but if you can you will help and people
can come along on fridays can't they
absolutely we're always there for
londoners and we will continue to
support them to our best abilities
okay good to talk to you as always
thanks a lot
thank you bye thanks bye-bye for now now
we'll have the latest as amnesty
international warns competitors and
delegates alike heading to next month's
beijing winter olympics not to become
complicit in a propaganda exercise that
[Music]
hello again everybody amnesty
international has warned competitors and
delegates heading to the beijing winter
olympics not to become complicit in a
propaganda exercise by the chinese
government the human rights organization
accuses china of persecuting uiga
muslims in xinjiang and restricting
freedom of speech in hong kong let's
find out more about it should we tom
standing by in beijing a lot of
countries certainly as far as the
diplomats have concerned are saying
we're not coming
yeah morning okay that's correct there
is this diplomatic boycott but there are
athletes going even if the politicians
won't be and they've been put in a
pretty tricky position amnesty's saying
they should be allowed to put their
opinion out there that the freedom of
speech should be guaranteed i think this
is something beijing is alive to just
recently an
official who's organizing the games says
that any behavior or speech that is
against the olympic spirit especially
against the chinese laws and regulations
should be punished there is an element
of threat there the punishment isn't
specified it could be according to the
olympic regulations but that mention of
chinese laws will make athletes a bit
more wary about speaking out is a very
tricky position for them to be in they
just want to go there there's enough
pressure competing at the olympics but
it's the ioc the international olympic
committee that's chosen beijing as the
host and put them there
okay for now thank you thanks a lot tom
well let's talk about it in more detail
should we joining us now
from amnesty international uk chief
executive sasha deshmukh hello t thank
you very much indeed for joining us on
the program this morning what are your
concerns about china hosting the winter
olympics
having me
the beijing winter olympics are taking
place in a dire and worsening human
rights situation in china you know you
highlighted just a few of the situations
in your introduction we're talking about
at least one million uyga muslims we're
being held in internment camps we're
talking about persecution of sexual
assault victims who speak up about their
experience
the systematic persecution of lawyers
and other people talking about human
rights and we could go on and on and on
the olympics are being used by the
chinese government as an attempt to
sports wash this terrible human rights
record
and really this diplomatic boycott while
welcome should only be the start of the
communication from governments from all
of us around the issues of human rights
and just how seriously we take human
rights in china and how we don't think
that this is acceptable
looking at beijing olympics uh pictures
that was the last time of course they
were on the world stage talking about
the winter olympics now and i suppose
that the obvious next question is do you
think that the athletes shouldn't go
well i understand that different
athletes will take different uh
positions about how they want to
participate and i just want to say that
you know i think all of us admire
enormously the dedication the skill you
know the perseverance of of athletes who
want to who train for years to
participate in the olympics what i think
is key especially given one of the major
issues of human rights in china is
freedom of expression is there are a
number of athletes who feel very
strongly about human rights issues want
to speak up appropriately and let's be
clear you know the ioc
regulations do say that athletes can
talk about the issues that they believe
in in media in social media and there
are a number of athletes who want to do
that we they need to know that they're
protected in doing so they're protected
they need to be protected by the olympic
authorities both the international
olympic authorities but also the british
olympic authorities and know that they
have all of our backs you know as their
supporters here in the uk as well
uh sasha is freezing out um china the
right way of dealing with um alleged
human rights abuses
well i think what we're talking about is
a real need to expose and to
to to look in scrutiny and for
governments to be clear about what's
happening in in in china in some ways i
think the issues are that the chinese
government has been uh denying that
there have been human rights abuses has
been denying access has been denying
visibility to what's happening
and actually governments and clearly i
think particularly the uk government
given where we are now need to be
calling out what's happening themselves
but actually also calling for proper
examination proper action in relation to
what's what's happening so i think the
enforcement of international law the
enforcement of the standards by which
all countries are expected to behave
that's the right action and it clearly
is something that's going to take
strong action strong force strong
communication by all of our strong
campaigning amnesty international has
launched a campaign to free the five and
clearly they're many more than five
people affected by human rights in china
but these are five very critical cases
just to give one example if you think
about your viewers watching this show
and how much you've had to you know
they've relied on you to communicate
about kovid one of those five people uh
zhang jian was sentenced to four years
imprisonment simply for reporting on the
covid pandemic in china and there are
four other cases of other human rights
and violations in that campaign i think
all of us need to be very vocal
and it's campaigns such as these and
clearly much deeper and loud and clear
action by governments including the uk
that is the right way to engage and
frankly what's absolutely needed for a
situation that is getting worse
okay sasha we must leave it there but
it's good to talk to you thank you for
taking the time to join us we appreciate
it thank you
thank you
still to come in the next hour of the
programme we are going to be talking
about a prime minister under increasing
pressure
the pork pie plot is what we are being
told about it i'll tell you why it's
called that in the next hour it's quite
intriguing but basically they've all
gathered against him the 20 of most of
the 2019 intake of mps
because of what happened they say in the
garden of downing street stay tuned for
more on the program this morning
[Music]